Mass Effect Andromeda has been in orbit
for a few weeks now and I'm sure you've
seen your fair share of horrible glitchy
gifts on Twitter well we should be
getting some fixes soon I'm Tony and
this is your patched gamespot news
update Andromeda's next patch drops
Thursday April sixth and it brings a
number of quote technical fixes to the
game these include a number of balance
tweaks bug squashes and better
lip-syncing remnant decryption keys will
also be cheaper to purchase from in-game
merchants so hopefully you'll have to
deal with fewer of those annoying space
Sudoku puzzles we have the full list of
changes over on gamespot so be sure you
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest fixes from bioware speaking of
which the studio has also released a
list of changes it hopes to make in the
future these include more character
creation options and better cinematics
and we all know that animation could use
some work but for more spacefaring
goofiness right now you can always check
out our saddest party in the Citadel
series where we play through the
original superior Mass Effect games
[Music]